on mène un premier bilan fait état en
tout cas de 5000 victimes dans les
combats de ces dernières 48 heures pour
bucarest seulement s'il est vrai que les
terroristes comme on les appelle
aujourd'hui n'ont plus aucune chance de
renverser le cours de l'histoire
il continue donc de faire régner la peur
on vient de le voir à l'instant et en
voici la confirmation avec le reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux françoise joly
et roger mode pour accéder à la
télévision qui est le quartier général
est le centre nerveux de la révolution
il n'avait que quelques centaines de
mètres à parcourir mais dans quelles
conditions
bucarest il y a à quelques heures à
peine nous sommes à quelques mètres un
bâtiment dans lequel il est extrêmement
difficile de pénétrer extrêmement
difficile d'approché parce que toujours
sous le feu nourri de la police et de la
minus alors en espérant une accalmie qui
peut être reviendra souvent les bouches
de métro à l'abri qu'on attend le moment
du passage
ces concours venez dans notre centre et
de ce métro l'armée a déjà pris position
depuis plus de 24 heures au bord de
l'épuisement premiers instants de répit
le but est là bas au bout de l'avenue le
bâtiment de la télévision et puis tout à
coup sans vraiment comprendre pourquoi
c'est le moment il faut sortir et courir
rester groupés dépêchez-vous de chaque
bâtiment de cette avenue peuvent partir
des rafales d'armes automatiques des
francs tireurs
ici chaque fenêtre est un péril chaque
passant un suspect
arrivé sur la place de la télévision
moment de tous les dangers
l'identification est ici une question de
survie
il ya quelques heures encore des tirs
d'armes automatiques parfait de cette
fenêtre
plus que quelques mètres mais en se
disant que même à l'intérieur des
bâtiments de la télé d'où on doit
absolument envoyer ces images des
miliciens sont infiltrés ce n'étaient
que 100 m dans les rues de bucarest 100
m mais avec le coeur à 160